una multitud temerosa yendo a la plaza
abastecerse
el temor ha hecho que los nigerianos
decidan almacenar alimentos y otros
elementos esenciales previniendo que se
den disturbios en el fin de semana de
elecciones en los últimos meses ha
aumentado los ataques contra símbolos
del estado y decenas de policías han
sido asesinados en los últimos meses
solo esta semana el miércoles asesinaron
a un candidato de la oposición del
partido laborista un suceso que se suma
a otros episodios de violencia y ataques
de extremistas islámicos
el partido laborista ha proporcionado
pruebas satisfactorias de la muerte de
su candidato En consecuencia la comisión
ha suspendido la elección en el distrito
según lo dispuesto por la ley ya vemos
comunicado esta decisión a nuestra
oficina Estatal de en radio
durante esta semana las autoridades se
han enfocado en evitar a toda Costa un
episodio de violencia y en dar
tranquilidad a las más de 93 millones de
personas que están registradas para
votar en los más de 176.000 centros de
votación el viernes la comisión
electoral traslado bajo Guardia al
material electoral sensible y soldados
armados patrullaron las calles 24 horas
antes de abrir las urnas
entre tanto comunidades religiosas
dedicaron la víspera de las elecciones
para orar por unos comicios justos y
pacíficos Nigeria en donde la religión
es una gran parte de la vida de las más
de 200 billones de personas está
dividida entre el cristianismo y el
islam
oraremos por la misericordia de Dios
para el país de Nigeria y le diremos que
estamos entregando las elecciones bajo
la dirección del Espíritu Santo a Dios
por una lección pacífica libre y bien
coordinada Se espera que los resultados
de los 36 estados lleguen cinco días
después de la jornada de votación